welcome everyone to this quick video on
the order flows Delta scalper and Apple
stock or Monday August 29 2016 my name
is Michael Altos I'm the founder and
trader at order flows comm quick
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational informational purposes only
and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract to make any other type of
investment decision futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading anyway those were sufficient
risk emotion consider trading past
performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results so what are
the tools used in this presentation it's
the order flows Dolphin scalper which
runs on the ninja trader training the
platform you can download the ninja
trader trading platform for free at
ninja trader calm you can trade stocks
you can trade futures you trade Forex
with it ok so one of the questions I get
asked once in a while is hey can I use
order flows software with equities with
stocks
honestly I don't trade stocks I'm not an
expert in stocks I don't claim to be I'm
a futures person I've been in futures my
entire career however you know I mean
people have been asking so I thought I
put together a short video on you know
some of the tools that I have that can
be used with stocks so this is the Delta
scalper which measures changes in supply
and demand as read by the Delta now I
chose for this demonstration I chose
Apple stock actually I looked at three
stocks yesterday Apple CME and Goldman
Sachs you know I want something that's a
highly capitalized stock honesty you
know it's a very small sample yes I
understand that I'm not trying to curve
fit it there was no signals in the CMB
stock there was no signals in goldman
sachs stocks they were several though in
Apple stock so again that's why I'm
showing it using this video and honestly
I don't know what type of chart to use
right now I'm you know I pulled it up on
a ran in on a one-minute chart okay
again I'm not a stock trader I'm just
putting it out there for you guys make
your own decision one way or the other
so this is
Apple one-minute stock and you know
here's a 30 is cash open and you know
trading nothing no signals got a signal
here about 10 20 right around this was
that 106 60 area in here you got the buy
signal and you know it was wasn't the
low it was you know just a little bit
off the low but you know Delta's scalper
doesn't pick highs or lows it picks
changes in supply and demand so what
it's telling you now is this market is
shifting to a demand driven market
potentially and you know it's takes a
while to get going but you know it made
a nice move up from the 106 60 area all
the way up you know up to 107 20
honestly I've been happy to take profits
came in a little bit traded back all the
way up above you know 107 4107 you know
25 30 area you got a sell signal so it
shifted from a demand driven market to a
supply driven market and it starts come
off go sideways you know this is about
12 12 40 Chicago time my charts are in
Chicago time and then it gives another
signal and 107 15 just around 125 I mean
but you know really this is the first
signal here that you should be looking
to get short on this is just you know a
bonus confirmation signal and it trades
back down to the 106 88 area so you know
say you missed this one you know this
was a nice one here from 107 you know 10
area down don't 106 80 got another
signal here just ahead of the close and
you know closed here at 106 82 now this
one didn't really work that great you
know it popped up a little bit before
selling off but you know honestly this
is encouraging I said you know I'm not a
stock guy I very rarely look at stocks
but you know people have been asking
someone purchased this honestly the
other day then wants to trade stocks
with it and you know there's you can I
mean you know if this is how it's going
to look on you know when it gives
signals then you know it's going to be a
great indicator but honestly I said you
know my sample is still quite small but
you know going forward
we'll be watching it every day to see
how let's see how it develops but I mean
you know if you can you know buy down
here around the 106 60 area you know get
out you know one on 720 then get short
around the 107:20 down back to 106 80
you know you don't need a lot of trades
per day and it's not about having tons
of trades a day you know having 10 20
trades a day what you want you want to
have a few high quality trades
decent trades you don't want to be in
and out in and out in and out because
it's gonna it's gonna chop you up and
you know feed you to the alligators so
to speak that's not a nice analogy but
it's kind of gruesome but still you know
if you know going forward and know I'm
costly I'm gonna watch it and you know
I'll continue to post videos you know
shown when it worked and when it failed
but I think today monday was was a very
encouraging day but again now I'm a
futures guy I'm not an equities guy and
one day doesn't make a trading system
you know make uh you know make million
dollars in one day but you know what if
most days are going to look as nice as
this then you know it is probably worth
it to start to start following it a bit
more again you know I just have it on a
one minute chart depends on your
training style you maybe use five
minutes maybe use even 30 seconds you
use two minutes maybe you use range bars
maybe use Renko charts minutes there's a
whole myriad of different ways you can
use it you know I usually start with
either a range chart or a minute a
one-minute chart I put a one minute
chart come on make sure the signals are
firing and you know at the end of the
day I look back on my chart and I
thought holy this is this is nice
but at the same time you know I had
goldman sachs stock running and I had CM
e stock running and there were no
signals on either of them but you know
you need I think a stock needs certain
amount of volatility you know for the
Delta scalper could be effective that's
why I chose these three stocks you know
you may have more recommendations for me
if you do just shoot me an email and you
know I'll run it on on what you suggest
okay so thanks for watching the
video to learn more about the trading
software that used in this presentation
which is the Delta scalper and how you
can use it in your trading or all you
want to use order phone your trading
visit my main website WWF luscom so
again the thank you and I hope to hear
from you
and see you on the inside bye bye